quand il revient à la réunion jean paul
disney d'art soit dans ce cabinet de
bioénergie à sainte-clotilde agents edf
à la retraite installé dans le sud de la
france
jean paul disney lhdaa est le fils aîné
de jeanne paul visnelda la célèbre
guérisseuse figure haute en couleurs du
paysage magique locale
elle pratique aussi bien la médecine par
les plantes la divination les faces
magnétique et bien sur l'exorcisme
tout ce que vous faites c'est votre
maman qui vous a appris elle m'a appris
tout ça tout ce qui est sûr magnifique
depuis l'âge de 12 ans je les assister à
tous à vous retenir t1 vous savez quand
cette eau bénite représente la mer pour
le tout
aucun
j'essaie xerces espérons que des forces
diaboliques c'est au bout mais ce
qu'elle fait là vous le fait aussi
oui oui oui parce que regarder ça c'est
elle qui me l'a donnée je me déplace pas
avec une grande croix oui ça et ça c'est
son chapelet elle il ya son empreinte
énergétique là dedans jean-paul visnelda
affirme que sa mère lui a transmis son
don quand on a un pouvoir quand on a des
capacités sur le ténor g tic
on doit être capable de vaincre la
matière pour nous le prouver il se livre
à une petite démonstration et je vais
aller chercher les énergies qui est ici
et faire un effet de monde ici et
pouvoir de soulever
vous pouvez regarder pour pas qu'on dise
que que c'est du trucage chacun jugera
si la démonstration est convaincante
nous enlever les chevaux sur cette femme
elle est clairement convaincu vous
mettez la tête n'a depuis des semaines
elle se plaint de douleurs dans tout le
corps sans vous touchez l'homme se sent
que vous avez le dos comme une table à
repasser
je vais d'abord voir votre taux
vibratoire je tiens juste votre main
comme ça
homologues des énergies nocives négative
on jette c'est à dire où en est on est
chez nous
on vous voit aussi presque tiré un fil
qu'est ce que vous faites quand vous
faites ça choque magnétiseur à sa façon
de faire des passes magnétique
oui quand j'enlève c'est à dire que les
mauvaises énergies qui a et ben j'enlève
aussi de cette façon là c'est devenu en
caoutchouc main d'henry allez c'est bon
[Musique]
décédé en 1991 john paul visnelda repose
au cimetière de l'étang salé
à
communiquer encore avec elle oui
d'ailleurs chez moi j'ai une 30 photos
que j'ai mis dans mon séjour et deux
fois par semaine pour communiquer moi je
pose la main sur la croix
ce centre a vu une vibration
c'est pour ça que quand je fais une
imposition des mains sur les personnes
la personne ressent cette vibration à
l'intérieur du corps dans une petite rue
de l'étang salé jean-paul visnelda nous
emmène à présent vers la maison de sa
mère aujourd'hui inhabités il reste dans
le jardin le petit oratoire qu'elle
avait fait construire et qui est encore
régulièrement visités c'était quoi ici
ça c'est le ciel venait prier tout le
temps là et les gens brûlent des bougies
idrissi et ils mettent des des petits
billets de veut enfin ce qu'ils
demandent quoi voilà tous les plaques de
remerciements elle a soigné des miliers
de personnes oui oui oui
le lendemain nous retrouvons jean paul
visnelda pour une nouvelle consultation
l'homme qui le reçoit ce matin se sent
mal et fait des cauchemars et vous
pensez beaucoup plus en quelque chose d
paranormal département par rapport à ce
que vous ressentez vous sentez une
présence ou bien l'homme évoque alors
une ancienne compagne qui lui apparaît
tant rêver le tourmente
[Musique]
vous êtes sûr que lé présent c'est à
dire qu'elle vient alors ce que vous
allez faire
mettez vous debout là comme ça
maintenant fermer les yeux là vous allez
sentir le vide le vide quand et un
moment donné et votre corps va commencer
à flotter la paix et vous avez vous
sentir tirer comme si que quelqu'un au
tir derrière et ce sera sûrement cette
personne là si nous parce qu'elle ne
verra rien et ans de prépa au sein d' à
bout la santé et les terres hier vous
laisse derrière elle est derrière vous
elle est derrière vous
vous allez me ménard jean paul visnelda
va procéder à ce qu'il appelle à
désenvoûtement genève en ciel présente
voilà c'est là votre respiration a
commenté
voilà voilà voilà
je vous demande de libérer
[Applaudissements]
libérez corps
il vous orienter
il faut le laisser tranquille je vous ai
pas repartir
l'un d'eux vous venez je vais vous aider
à partir voir dieu du film nous
supplions humblement pour nous délivrer
les esprits inferno de leur piège
[Musique]
chaque fois qu'il revient à la réunion
jean paul visnelda reçoit ainsi des
dizaines d'hommes et de femmes qui
l'affirment soulager des mots les plus
divers pour chaque consultation
ils demandent 50 euros une participation
qui le jugent minimes censés payer juste
ses frais de voyage et de séjour bon
pour que cela fonctionne la première
chose est sans doute d'avoir envie d'y
croire en paix comme on dit
non